you
our design process is nonlinear we we
are always engaged in problems of
culture where we're building what that
society is like what its people are like
what our clients are we're always
engaged with technologies how do they
build what are the materials and methods
available to us what kind of labor force
goes into it we look at the
particularity zuv this site over another
side to the degree that a geography can
inform that you're working on something
but none of this usually adds up to a
synthetic moment they come into a kind
of productive conflict our task is to
see how the the evidence of of this
information and this material that we
are researching ricochet off of each
other to to imagine how a project an
architectural problem arises out of that
the architectural problem doesn't arise
out of this of course it is something
that you project onto it and of course
we have our own agendas missions and
thesis that underlie a lot of our work
well building in Beijing to start with
was a very difficult task for us the
initial task of going there and
understanding their means and methods of
production was I think relatively easy
and you can see from the work that it is
so literal at one level in working with
their trades their brick their mode of
construction the the discursive moment
between design and production was much
more vast a project that took 23 months
to build took 23 years to negotiate
probably out of our own ignorance of not
being able to find the right channels to
deliver the project contractually that
makes a huge difference to learn how to
speak the language if not literally
culturally speaking the language of the
society in which you're going to be a
part of so a lot of what we do now as a
result of that project is to try to
understand social practices legal
practices casual practices if you like
of how a project is produced as a kind
of infrastructure for an actual design
itself it's impossible really to have a
successful design process to understand
where you invest that time and the
Beijing lesson was a was a difficult one
for a project that's only 2,000 square
feet two or three months to build that
should have been you know done in a much
faster speed
probably I would tell them to find the
right partner find the right
collaborative platform to understand the
financial parameters of a problem but
not to dwell on the details of this or
that dollar because the larger mission
the larger spear the the speed at which
something can be done and the the
general effort the bigger picture
essentially is more important and if you
get those right the details can probably
follow
well there's no doubt that with the
accessibility of information and of
knowledge there's a collapse of time and
space and so the cultural differences
that would have been there are now
beginning to to come into confluence but
it's also more curious i would say that
how the same bit of information or the
similar pieces of knowledge are
interpreted so differently in Tehran and
in New York so I'm more interested in in
identifying those differences and and
capitalizing on the uniqueness of that
moment because you remember that
architecture is not like a Nike sneaker
it isn't actually everywhere
architecture at the end is unique each
building sits in a site in a certain
moment in a very different way and for
the most part that's what we do